je pars à la guerre dans mon art je peux
à la guerre en tenue de combat je
n'aimerais pas être à ta place tu crois
le come back to je ne roulais pas à toi
à mourir à la guerre comme à la guerre
je vous serais cris de jo
tu pars à la guerre dont on a tous mais
tu pars à la guerre en tenue de combat
cherché à
me fait sourire je sais que c'est toi
qui mordra la poussière tout toi à
mourir la guerre comme à la guerre coût
100 char
tu joues bien tu as repos dans la guerre
comme à la guerre
maintenant
tu fais
toi à mourir à la guerre comme à la
guerre jolis coups sont permis rachel
à la guerre comme à la guerre
civile m
à ton tour à mourir pour masquer les
coûts sont chers